à
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parlait sport l'émission à ne surtout
pas manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local au programme aujourd'hui
comme toujours des analyses techniques
des décryptages et surtout une dose de
bonne humeur pour m'accompagner
aujourd'hui nos chroniqueurs sont avec
nous sur ce plateau présentation en
musique on commence à ma droite musique
c'est ça un passionné de sport il adore
la voix le cyclisme sur route le
cyclisme sur piste le roller et j'en
passe il a été champion du monde de
cyclisme sur piste masters ce capital
vienne dujarrier tu avais je suis
toujours champion du monde en titre si
les gens habiter le monde effectivement
jusqu'à octobre octobre cette année
normalement si tout va bien voilà tous
les sports ou que j'ai citées ce sont
nos passions cc c'est le minimum d'un
oui
on continue notre tour de table à gauche
musique vous le connaissez tous et
l'italienne lovers y aller les
journalistes chez tv 78 oh attendez il
ya un problème ce n'est pas sa musique
et bien non c'est bixente mes rayons
santisteva qui sera le remplaçant de
grégory sur cette émission il est aussi
journaliste chez tb 78 il connaît très
bien le sport local et il est d'origine
basque comme vous pouvez l'entendre
bonjour michel teixido journée qu'elle
je suis ravi d'être ici parmi des
légendes
moi je moi j'ai grandi en regardant je
séchais les cours quand vous regardez
voilà donc je suis c'est un plaisir
d'être ici avec vous on est très content
en tout cas de vous avoir je sais vous
serez à la hauteur vous allez bien
remplacer grégory peut-être il reviendra
pas sur cette émission on sépare je vais
me faire taper s'ils recommencent à
prendre sa place parce qu'il y en a plus
on continue notre tour de table musique
il est de retour après un break à la
montagne il est en forme il est bien
bronzé il est motivé notre gladiateurs
pierre chevallier du rugby-club de
versailles et avec lui pendant une arme
des amis forme et bonheur à tous oui
effectivement bien oxygénées
s'étendraient bien bronzé après des
semaines de rêve une semaine de rêve
donc en pleine forme pour une magnifique
les jeux magnifiques qui faisait froid
la nuit donc canon marchait bien
c'était canon et vous avez révisé de
quand même tous les sujets pour reparler
de gérer leurs jt j'avais un peu de
temps pour suivre l'actualité
enfin notre dernier chroniqueur musique
c'est une légende vivante un mythe il
est incroyable spectaculaire blagueur
extraordinaire inimitable on est
toujours très heureux de l'avoir dans
cette émission coach jour miss
ex-entraîneur de plaisir est avec nous
bonjour à tous quand allez-vous coach
pleine forme a fait deux formes détendu
aussi oui oui toujours
là petit basque illégal rugby aussi avec
est un
petit bijou à greg mon rétablissement
bon rétablissement rigoriste on
retrouvera normalement dans la prochaine
émission mais bon sait-on jamais les
remplaçants des fois peuvent devenir
titulaire alors avant de passer au
programme de l'émission commence tout de
suite par du rugby en illinois qui
brille en ce moment les au bar et a été
désigné homme du match lors de la
victoire de l'équipe de france des moins
de 20 ans 47 avant face au pays de
galles pour le tournoi jeunes des six
nations les au bar et qui est l'homme en
forme du moment et l'a réalisé de belles
performances avec son club du stade
français il est confirmé ce fait un nom
dans le monde du rugby est ce que c'est
une surprise ou pas on en parle depuis
quelques émissions de ce lait au bar est
ce que c'est une surprise
vous donner la parole pierre vous qui
connaissez bien il vient du rugby-club
de versailles jeunes versailles et au
départ la granta six ans je sais ça et
c'est u c'est pour deux raisons ce n'est
pas une surprise la première c'est que
c'est une affaire de famille chez les
bars et michel
grand-père a été président du rc
versailles pendant de nombreuses années
arnaud son fils après avoir été joué au
racing notamment où il a été champion de
france crabos est revenu à versailles
j'ai joué avec lui d'un des temps que
les moins de vingt ans ne peuvent pas
connaître et puis donc les eaux qui
arrive derrière qui a fait son école de
rugby à versailles avant de partir à
massy et puis là c'est une lente
ascension parce que la deuxième raison
c'est que c'est un bon boulaga ce qui
est élevé au grain qui a pris le temps
qu'a pris le temps de tout et qui est
qui est bien conseillé notamment par par
son père et son grand père qui est bien
entouré qui est bien dans sa tête c'est
un c'est vraiment un super gamin qui a
des cadets des notes physique assez
assez étonnante c1 c'est vraiment un
beau bébé pour 1 m 89 pour 89 kg a passé
une demi-heure bien sûr une belle
armoire versaillaise et rei commence
effectivement à faire des merveilles au
au stade français en dix ans 12 ou 15 et
puis jusqu'à jusqu'à l'équipe de france
des u18 et u20 et où il a été là par
exemple il ya ya ya à peine une semaine
meilleurs joueurs de l'équipe de france
des u20 contre contre le pays de galles
au pays de galles donc une belle
performance à l'arrière est vraiment un
tout bon tout bon espoir du rugby
francilien et français jean vous le
connaissez vous non pas du tout je le
connais comme ça mais par ôta de
capitaux est-ce que ça me surprend pas
qu'ils soient à ce niveau là est ce que
ça fait partie il fait partie de cette
nouvelle génération de bleu qui est qui
émerge tout à fait tout à fait et la
chance qu'on a actuellement sous l'ère
de berthier c'est que c'est un
sélectionneur qui fait confiance à la
jeunesse contrairement avant on n'avait
qu'un tendance à avoir du mal à faire
confiance aux jeunes et ont rappelé
toujours les trentenaires croyait qu'ils
allaient sauver la patrie et là on peut
on peut que lui reconnaître d'avoir
d'avoir su franchir le cap et dire je
fais confiance aux jeunes et je monte
une équipe de france capable d'aller
jusqu'en 2023 pour être championne du
monde et ses joueurs alors pluie bien
sûr ne fera pas partie de ce lourd 23 le
penser qu'ils lisent pas mal il sera
parmi les 23
il faudrait qu'ils aient dû me voit il
faut donner blessé il faudrait des
blessés parce que il fait pas partie des
ja du groupe élargi donc c'est compliqué
de faire rentrer un joueur qui fait pas
partie on va dire des 45 ou
46 n'a donc cessé peu compliqué je pense
que non pour cette coupe du monde n'a ce
sera juste la coupe du monde c'est
l'année prochaine hilare il a tout juste
20 ans ce garçon a 19 ans et 20 ans mois
d'août voilà donc par contre ça peut
être effectivement un joueur pour les
prochaines échéances du groupe france
hélas oui pourquoi pas là pourquoi pas
parce qu'il a il a des landes qualité et
la veine tâche qu'il a aussi surtout
c'est qu'il est polyvalent et je vous
dis centre ou arrière donc la
polyvalence on le sait pertinemment que
en équipe nationale les joueurs
polyvalents mais on privilégie en tant
que sélectionneur les joueurs
polyvalente par rapport à cette
situation par rapport à un joueur qui ne
l'occupent qu'un seul poste parce que
c'est la polyvalence qui me semble est
ce que c'est un joueur d'avenir
justement oui oui c'est clairement un
joueur d'avenir parce qu'il est parce qu
il est il des îles et dans le morphotype
très à la mode dans le morphotype des
joueurs des joueurs modernes parce qu'il
est il est puissant il est athlétique cd
où vous le rappeliez cesser une armoire
de muscles il est bien temps qu'est et
moi ce que je suis ce que je voulais
rappeler ces camps la saison dernière il
était barré c'est le cas de le dire par
un certain nombre de joueurs en dise
quand il avait à l'ouverture notamment
par sanchez il a eu sa chance cette
saison là en début de saison quand
sanchez est parti en sélection argentine
il ya second aussi qui j'ai qui joue qui
joue quand même qui est numéro un en dix
actuellement au stade français est donc
là il ya il ya aussi cette polyvalence
qui va le servir parce qu'ils jouaient
12 il n'y a pas si longtemps à massy
notamment et en équipe de france hélas
hélas gonzalo quesada quesada les seuils
à l'arrière et à l'arrière il ya là il
ya la concurrence avec hamdaoui mais il
ya peu et peut prétendre à plusieurs
postes parce qu'ils la c1 comme on dit
dans notre jargon c1 c'est un gamin qui
pue le rugby et qui équipaient qui
baigne dedans depuis le depuis le début
et est vraiment on a on ad on a des très
très belle aux attentes pour ce pour ce
garçon qui est qui a bien mature et quoi
cacher il vous plait come back comme
disait pierre c'est quelqu'un qui garde
les pieds sur terre pour avoir discuté
avec lui il sait quand il doit saisir sa
chance son entraîneur gonzalo quesada et
très élogieux à son égard il dit que
c'est un très bon joueur comme il y en a
beaucoup d'ailleurs mais que lui il faut
qu'il travaille qui sait qu'il peut pour
essai qui sait qu'il a le temps et c'est
quelqu'un qui a du sang froid on le voit
pas ce que laissait les minutes il les
saisit là contre le pays de galles c'est
trois pénalités transformées 4
transformations des c'est donc sur les 4
premiers essais quand il fallait les
transformer pour augmenter l'écart il
fait 6 7 points tous puissent un jour
qui met énormément d'intensité dans son
jeu moi quand je vois jouer j'ai
toujours l'impression impressionné par
l'intensité qui met à 10 devant comme ça
il ya le verrier comme d'habitude il
faut pas lui mettre trop de pression les
jeunes encore non non non alors ça faut
arrêtez moi c'est un discours que je ne
supporte pas chez les français ils sont
jeunes faut leur laisser le temps sagan
on lui a laissé le temps je parlais de
vélo vite fait sa garde on lui a laissé
le temps dans le mec il a été maillot il
a été maillot il était champion du monde
très jeune donc non je suis désolé quand
on a les capacités il faut y aller et il
faut il faut après là où en effet il
faut laisser une
un peu de temps c'est sur la maturité
physique parce que bien sûr que dans le
rugby je pense que les meilleures années
c'est à partir de 25 ans quand on a fini
complètement d'exploiter qu'on
d'exploiter son physique physique là
depuis au moins de deux ans à peu fermé
il va encore il va encore évoluer vous
avez passé entre 25 et 30 ans michael
ossi voilà et d'un logement et du corps
et le corps évolue encore dans ces
années donc il a encore un peu de marge
il est encore moyen de moyens de
travailler donc oui sur ce point là je
dirais qu'il faut laisser le temps mais
il faut prendre l'expérience et
l'expérience ces jeunes cons là qu'on la
gagne très rapidement avant de passer
aux thèmes suivants programme de
l'émission un petit mot sur cette équipe
de france de rugby à vous plaît pierre
chevallier les à les appeler à
peut-être cardio léobard il ira chez les
jeunes puisque c'est cette vie de cette
génération nous parlait donc par les
gens qui arrivent à maturation là et qui
frappent à la porte d edéa déjà un peu
court au bourget en france 2023 mais
peut-être en 2027 est vrai sais pas
peut-être il y sera je pense il y sera
donc oui cette équipe de france elle et
elle est enthousiasmante elle est
capable de gagner avec la manière de
planter un grand nombre d'essai on
n'avait plus l'habitude il ya un état
d'esprit qui me plaît beaucoup il ya les
ya pas forcément que des stars on a on a
dû pour meilleur joueur mondial mais qui
comme tous les autres est au service de
l'équipe et ça pour le coup le gourou
galtier a réussi à façonner un groupe où
le très compétitif au point qu'on se
demande c'est quand charles olivo va
revenir s'il a sa place en troisième
ligne parce que hayden usa bat les
deuxièmes et troisièmes i en défense
notamment abattent un travail monstrueux
ils sont capables de gagner des matches
vraiment au couteau comme au pays de
galles et là on les attend évidemment
les attend au tournant contre ces
diables d'anglais pour une victoire et
le grand chelem qui nous échappe depuis
2010 donc elle me plaît
difficile saurez-vous 300 kilomètres
dans l'après midi plus le match de rugby
à 21h c'est une grosse journée quand
vous allez devant la télé compris gens
qui prônent aussi peut-être sur ce
france angleterre le grand chelem pour
l'équipe de france et après on passe à
la suite j'espère qu'on va les tordre
c'est comme ça
qu'on va les tordre on va les tordre
rugbystiquement malheureusement on va
dire yako réchauffé mais sa tournée
pendant l'arbitrage aussi parce que
malheureusement
c'est lequel c'est plus peur s'est fait
peur très peur très peur ça dépendant
aussi que parce que fera le genre
n'est qu'un symptôme france plein
jusqu'au stade un jour peut-être
l'équipe de france est quand même
largement plus forte que l'équipe
d'angleterre après sur un match c'est
vrai que c'est un jour que voilà les
agressés battus par les irlandais avec
beaucoup de défaites pour
passer l'humilité on a une équipe de
france qui est quelle grande humidité
c'est étonnant et ça à mon avis moi je
vois bien que je viens à l'essai dès les
cinq premières minutes histoire de
rectifier un peu de
cette édition c'est que galles et
référent sur les pronostics pour le coup
alors on espère voir en tout cas aller
au bar et disputer ce type de rencontre
les dans les prochaines années alors
nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler de l'élimination du psg en
8e de finale de la ligue des champions
face au real madrid coup de projecteur
également sur la 80e édition du
paris-nice qui est partie des yvelines
de mantes la ville mais avant de parler
de ce thème on va parler de la coupe de
france de football
[Musique]
on va donc commencer par la coupe de
france de football nous avons suivi
toutes leurs épopées ici sur ce plateau
nous avions même réalisé un avant-match
versailles n'a pas réussi à se hisser en
finale de la coupe de france ces genres
de la cité royale se sont inclinés 2 à 0
sur le terrain de nice après avoir
connu on va dire 45 minutes plutôt bonne
où il aurait pu faire à éventuellement
jeu égal et peut-être remporter la
victoire on écoute l'un des défenseurs
de l'équipe m'a quant à travaux on est
fier du parcours qu'on a on a parcouru
et on se dit que ben voilà on va se
servir de ce match
face à nice pour pour bien finir cette
saison et atteindre les objectifs qui
est étonné alors la question sur ce
thème est ce que versailles est tombé
avec les honneurs oui ou non oui bon
vous jean louis pour vous oui pour tout
le monde pas de pad duel ou cherchez pas
le duel aujourd'hui à michel n'était pas
tout de suite ce compliqué pour
versailles de diane sont pas tombés avec
les honneurs contre un club de ligue 1
comme assez solide puisque nice la force
et ça c'est la solidité défensive aussi
donc là ménisque et peut être le futur
deuxième de liga
pour l'instant genre alors de quoi
est-ce qu'ils sont tombés avec les
honneurs c'est vers ça y est alors je
dis oui un grand oui un grand oui
monsieur quand on regarde le match quand
je disais sur le plateau que j'ai
l'impression que personne ne veut d'un
versailles à ce niveau là mais je crois
que ça s'est encore malheureusement
vérifié sur sur le début du match parce
que
même au niveau des commentaires il ya
quand même deux actions de niçoise où ça
vaut au moins une des deux cerveaux
carton rouge et l'arbitré ne le sors pas
ne le sors pas ça peut tout changer
quand même une demi finale de coupe de
france mais je pense quand elle sort ne
lèvera pas de l'idée une affiche nantes
versailles ça n'intéresse pas grand
monde si ce n'est versailles et et l'île
de france alors je pense ce que je vais
être un peu cru mais là c'est pas moi
qui le disaient mais je regardais j'ai
regardé celui finale et quand même des
spécialistes de la discipline comme
monsieur courbis qui et qui justement
commenter et qui disait qu'ils étaient
soi mc notamment puisqu'on sortie du
direct et d'ici et sur rmc et 10 et là
je trouve quand même bizarre que les
arbitres ne relève pas c'était énorme
faute sur sur le versailles et de
pourquoi pourquoi on en fait on fait
abstraction de l'enjeu on change tout on
ne voulait pas moi mans on ne m'enlèvera
pas de l'idée que versailles a dérangé à
ce niveau de la compétition
alors il n'a pas besoin de ça à nice il
faut une excellente deuxième mi temps je
pense que le le le il ne voulait rien
notamment qui marque un superbe but et
qui fait un geste un peu zidanesque sur
le deuxième neuf et voilà il me 2,2
trois joueurs dans le vent est sûre sur
un dribble mais mais mais quand même je
pense que versait avec ses chaises
notamment si ça avait été arbitré
normalement et ya passé pas une faute
c'est 2,6 et d'y aller il ya deux
assassinats et là au moins 5 août un oui
je prends à 36 la grosse faute non mais
c'est non mais c'est long ça vous laisse
à vos roues jeu savant rouge annonce
arrive ça irait sajoo moi je suis
versailles et l'autre jupette à la jambe
tomber avec les honneurs oui évidemment
parce que c'est une demi-finale de coupe
de france eq c1 c'est un parcours
imaginés par arnaud en début d'année
même si on l'espère ch à chaque fois sur
ce plateau un club aller très loin voir
un club pendant deux minutes et partout
aller très loin c'est pas forcément si
rarement arrivé à des équipes de
nationale 2 depuis le début de la
compétition versailles joue bien
versailles joue juste et quand on arrive
à partir des quarts de finale demi
finale évidemment encore plus on tombe
sur des gros jusqu'à jusqu alors
versailles avait été plutôt épargné
entre guillemets avec un tour difficile
en huitième contre bergerac c'est là où
c'est des taux les taux les plus
difficiles de ces équipes qui se
ressemblent et nice faut pas oublier
qu'il avait sorti l'om cette sortie le
psg donc en gros c'est c'est plus
qu'avec les honneurs cédé 0,2 contre une
équipe qui tombeur de grands de vie
sains et puis j'ai pour compléter ce que
disait jeannot je dirais que en plus le
sursaut match de demi finale c'est à
l'image ce match est à l'image de leur
parcours ils ré ils font plus que de la
résistance en première mi-temps en plus
avec des coups du sort qui aurait pu
faire basculer de l'autre côté et puis
il tombe sur rbe de but parce que parce
que nice est une très bonne équipe
entraînée par un très bon entraîneur et
que et voilà mais c'est ce que la maison
le bien qui nous ont finalement rejoint
qui nous ont emporté c'est gravé à
jamais et finalement ils ont ils ont eu
du mal quand même en première période et
niçois face à versailles je sais la
résistance est ce qu'on sait pas dire
moment il ya le charrier il c'est
possible finalement encore au bois qui à
0-0 à la pause est ce qu'on se dit pas
tenir il pleurait le aux tirs aux buts
et remporter la victoire mais bien sûr
que si à la mi-temps 0-0 c'était le
premier challenge à remporter parce que
justement ça permettait de créer le
doute dans l'esprit des nids soir à
l'ats ils ont pris un but sur les dix
premières minutes de la deuxième mi
temps je voyage je crois que c'était de
deux minutes après le retour des
vestiaires donc donc voilà ça met un
gros coup au moral et c'est vrai que les
niçois ont vraiment accéléré montée d'un
cran en retour de au retour des
vestiaires et ça est sale et laid
versailles et n'ont pas su et n'ont pas
pu le pas pu le faire voilà bon il était
il n'avait pas à rougir de toute façon
personne ne voulait de en finale
comme dit jean personne ne voulait de la
finale on leur a mis que des bâtons dans
les roues pendant tout le temps tout
leur parcours
ils ont ils ont ils ont fait ce qu'ils
devaient s'arrêter bien un petit 2 1
pour pour pour
s'affairer bayik voilà il aurait pu
marquer bon il aurait pu s'en prendre un
troisième aussi et une barre
transversale en fin de rencontre n'aura
pas été passée c'était pas la déranger
c'était juste dire on a marqué un but et
en a marqué un but
[Musique]
et
est ce que finalement le fait d'avoir
joué à nice aussi vous pensez que ça ça
jouer forcément sur cette rencontre car
sur hélène si les niçois ont été d'une
grande élégance et classe en prenant en
charge les frais de déplacement de
l'équipe versaillaise ça je pense que le
club et la ville en leur en est
reconnaissant mais évidemment même si
versailles est pas encore une ville de
tifosi de de 100% foot ce qu'ils ont
réussi à créer on va pas reparler de
l'interdiction aussi de 2 diffusé sur
écran géant place du marché non ça c'est
encore une hauteur un autre sujet mais
sur l'échangé des tendeurs de droit qui
n'ont pas voulu place du marché c'était
ok pour les quarts de finale et que ça
ne demandait qu'à casse instituée
s'institutionnaliser et à se pérenniser
justement cette ce côté ce côté
supporters de foot et oui oui ça aurait
changé la donne si on avait pu avoir à
voir ça au moins en ile de france on
sait on sait qu'il ya un pour l'instant
encore un problème de stade qui est en
train d'être résolues pour la montée en
national mais au moins en ile de france
on avait parlé de créteil de charléty du
parc des princes puisque on en reparlera
un peu plus tard il sort il serait
peut-être changer un petit peu la donne
ce but là on aurait peut-être mieux le
but en 2e et en début de deuxième mais
on n'aurait peut-être pas pris on fait
beaucoup de choses avec des si il serait
peut-être changer un peu la donne vous
en pensez-quoi bixente bon au niveau du
parcours il ya rien à dire forcément sur
versailles sortir contre une équipe de
ligue 1 c'est ces honorables et même sur
le parcours on a beaucoup critiqué qui
n'était pas forcément
il sait pas tomber sur des gros
adversaire et finalement toulouse ce
week-end ses 6 0 contre amiens ils sont
premiers de ligue 2 il faut le rappeler
le niveau ligue 1
bergerac sas avait sorti deux équipes de
ligue 1 il me semble également donc le
tirage c'est le tirage et ils ont su
passer c'est tout ce qui compte est-ce
que ce parcours à votre avis valent leur
servir pour pour la suite et ce qu'ils
vont gagner en expérience à votre avis
est agent forcément forcément
sportivement lorsqu'on lorsqu'on vit ces
moments là ça reste gravé et ça resserre
lorsqu'on voit lorsqu'il veut se
représenter dans les mêmes conditions
de ces conditions de match à élimination
directe quelle que soit la compétition
ils vont avoir l'expérience ce qui fait
que ils vont ils vont appréhender le
match différemment parce qu'ils auront
déjà vécu ce genre de choses donc ça
bien sûr que ça va leur servir et je
rappelle qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
nouveaux joueurs aussi qui sont arrivés
cette saison à versailles avec le
nouveau projet forcément ça salit une
équipe pierre chevalier c'est un simon
si c'est un simon on croyait à la prise
rapide de pouvoir se frotter un contre
des plus gros de deux sur des gros
événements 3 2 passes et 2 passes et ses
tours là jusqu'à une demi finale de
coupe de france et ça c'est l'un des
gros avantages du foot par rapport au
rugby c'est à dire que le foot amateur
se confronte au foot professionnel et
puis la com et comme il prévoit
justement monte petit à petit par la
national voire jusqu'à la ligue 2 c'est
qu'une expérience qui compte de regarder
un petit peu comment ça se comment ça se
passe et surtout de pouvoir être capable
de croquer des les deux des ligues et
versailles est pour l'instant premiers
du championnat de nationale 2 avec 44
points six points d'avancé sur la
réserve de lorient qui ne peut pas à
monter a vu que c'est une réserve d'un
club professionnel et huit points
d'avancé sur chartres ça sent bon quand
même à vienne jarrier cette impression
ça commence à y restera deux matches il
reste je crois
un peu maudit match donc jack match donc
bien je pense que dans trois quatre
matches on va pouvoir commencer à avoir
véritablement sortir le champagne
seulement quand ta ligne d'arrivée
passée et ou alors quand quand
mathématiquement on ne peut qu être être
monté tout simplement mai mais c'est
vrai que la wii la dynamique est bonne
elles ont gagné tous leurs matches
depuis ce match contre contre nice donc
la dynamique est bonne n'y a pas eu de
contre coup parce que ça aurait pu être
le cas aussi c'est à dire mal vivre
cette défaite là bas s'est passé s'est
passé contre vannes
voilà est donc
maintenant baski moche que je pense
actuellement il faut déjà commencer à
préparer justement l'étape d'après parce
que bon wagon ils vont monter en
national
tant que c'est pas été mais ils vont le
projet il faut le il faut le continuer
c'est à dire que là il faut finaliser
les problèmes de stades pour pouvoir
jouer tranquillement l'année prochaine
il faut mettre en route le stade pour la
ligue 2 normalement pour le stade il
devrait y avoir ce fameux éclairage au
stade vauban dont il devrait y avoir
l'éclairage ce qui les a repêchés
apparemment il y aurait une dérogation
il serait octroyé faire des techniques
c'est soit soit c'est dur rétractable
soit c'est un éclairage mais qui est un
peu plus bas de base que la plupart des
stades équivalente normalement c'est sûr
à 99 9% pour la saison prochaine ils
joueront à un bon normalement je perds
je mange quand je parle de l'étape
d'après c'est c'est justement cette
histoire de stades beaucoup plus grand
pour pouvoir accueillir les matches de
l'image de ligue 2 parce qu'il va
falloir et puis après il va falloir
faire naître cet engouement sur la
région et sur le département alors par
la région mais sur le département des
yvelines pour créer des groupes de
supporters et créer une véritable
honneur parce que des matches de ligue 2
ça se ça se prépare et pas que pas que à
l'entraînement l'agroprix on va
continuer à parler de versailles bon la
vie dans les prochains sur les sports
s'est pas terminé à mon avis cette
aventure versaillaise alors versailles
jouera contre granville en tout cas ce
samedi à 19 mars on continuera
évidemment à les suivre on va passer
notre envolée du jour on continue à
parler football grigory canet avait
bossé sur cette envolée
heureusement et ne peut pas être présent
aujourd'hui du coup c'est vous bixente
qui allez vous y coller alors de quoi
allez vous nous parler aujourd'hui d'un
club qui continue de donner des sueurs
froides à ses supporters d'une équipe
que l'on pensait définitivement installé
dans le gotha du football européen d'un
groupe qui a pensé le temps d'un match
et demi même un peu plus avoir vaincu sa
vieille malédiction à l'accent espagnol
je parle bien sûr du pari exactement
paris saint germain il y avait eu au
match aller une prestation presque
référence on peut le dire au retour
également de 60 minutes de haut vol une
qualification qui semblait tendre les
bras au parisien à la mi temps ça sabrer
le champagne je crois dans la capitale
même et là c'est le drame un triplé de
karim benzema en 20 minutes et voilà le
real madrid en quart de finale de ligue
des champions la route vers la coupe aux
grandes oreilles se plaindre déjà pour
le club de la capitale alors comment est
ce possible
quel est le problème dans ce club
michael non les lobbys lyon où j'ai
l'impression j viager savions n'achète
pas l'expérience et la confiance comment
expliquer qu'une équipe en aussi bonne
posture gagné 1 0 à l'aller mené 1-0 au
retour vassy au moindre remous et
s'écroule totalement la malédiction a
encore frappé des images sombres
reviennent l'élimination contre
manchester united en 2019 en huitièmes
de finale également une victoire 2-0 à
old trafford au premier acte avant de
s'incliner 3-1 à domicile mais surtout
la déconvenue de 2010 est toujours en
huitièmes je crois qu'on le connaît tous
le revers 6 1 contre le fc barcelone
après l'avoir emporté 4-0 à l'aller une
trace indélébile dans l'histoire du
paris saint germain et qui nous a permis
à nous de tous perfectionner notre
espagnol ne dit plus le monde téméraire
montada je crois que c'est un
dictionnaire mais c'est possible
grégory aussi voulu soulever un autre
point commun à toutes ces images toutes
ces humiliations la fameuse boulette du
gardien de but vous connaissez tous ici
sont faibles son petit favori pour le
poste de portier à paris à chaque fois
les gaules ne sont pas les numéros un en
puissance de leur équipe leur coach
préférant instaurer un système de double
numéro un il ya eu donc le tandem trappe
arrêt au labo phone areola aujourd'hui
c'est navas roma sans hiérarchie des
gardiens pourtant talentueux parfois
expérimentés on semblait démuni dans ces
rendez vous couperet on dit qu'on
apprend de ses erreurs mais là elles
sont répétés au fil des années puis cet
aparté puisque je ne vais pas m'arrêter
sur tous les joueurs a critiqué sur le
match mais on n'a que 28 minutes encore
des dictionnaires justin symbolique
celui qui devait ramener la coupe au
club pour moi c'est le plus grand joueur
de l'histoire du football mais mais si
ces dernières années en ligue des
champions qu'est ce que c'est c'est
remonte à da contre la roma remonte à da
contre liverpool un historique 8,2
contre le bayern et on la doit être on
remonte jusqu'à l'année dernière une
élimination en huitièmes contre qui le
paris saint germain vous en concluez ce
que vous voulez moi je donne juste les
infos comme ça nous les milieux on
n'achète pas non plus la classe on peut
regretter un manque de fair play et
récurrent des dirigeants parisiens
préférant insister sur les erreurs
d'arbitrage plutôt que leur propre
mauvais choix après d'après plusieurs
médias nasser al-khelaifi et son
directeur sportif leonardo aurait tenté
après real psg d'entrer dans le
vestiaire des arbitres le président
aurait frappé délibérément le drapeau de
l'un des arbitres en le brisant c'est du
joli nom les millions enfin n'achète pas
les supporters il faut que les résultats
suivent derrière depuis quelques jours
de vives contestations émergent neymar
mêmes mais si je crois que c'est la
première fois que ça lui arrive dans son
stade par son équipe ont été
copieusement sifflé lors du match contre
bordeaux
de nombreuses banderoles demande le
départ de nasser al rai rai life i voici
le communiqué du collectif ultra à paris
nous savons ce que notre retour doit au
président nasser al-khelaifi il n'y a
rien ici de personnel mais force est de
constater qu'il n'est plus l'homme de la
situation
la situation du club nécessite désormais
une réorganisation complète à tous les
niveaux et la présence quotidienne de
son président oui car c'est le dernier
point commun à toutes ces remonte à un
homme était aux commandes nasser qui
porte dans son bilan tous ces échecs il
est peut-être temps pour la propriété
qatarienne de passer un grand coup de
balai est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
cette envolée de grégory mixé par
wisches et everio santisteva les ce que
vous êtes d'accord oui alors pourquoi
déjà on va commencer par vous pourquoi
vous n'êtes pas sûrs si ducati on
en est on est on est on est yvelinois
donc on suit et on était très content
d'avoir une très belle a trait au
parcours de versailles en coupe de
france mais après on a envie de voir le
paris saint-germain faire des beaux
parcours en coupe d'europe on leur
demande pas de gagner la coupe d'europe
tout le temps faim on leur demande de la
gagner une première fois on ne leur
demande pas de gagner tout le temps mais
je vois là mais se faire éliminer en 8e
de finale on était très content quand
ils ont perdu en finale contre le
contrôle bayern avec 7 se fane hull
heads qui était qui et elle était très
très sympa à vivre mais dernière perdre
perdre en demi finale voilà ça reste
respectable mais la perdre en huitièmes
de finale avec dans des conditions dans
des conditions où voilà en effet le
boulevard s'ouvre devant vous et un
grain de sable un grain de sable qui met
toute la machine en branle s'est passé
c'est pas normal à ce niveau et quand on
a des cantons là tant de temps
d'objectifs voilà autant d'objectifs
affichée moi je j'ai du mal et juste
après cette défaite ben voila j'ai mis
sur les réseaux urbains s'assigne le
départ de
lasserre et les résidents leonardo
ap papa au real et je pense que là il ya
quand même une aventure qui se termine
parce que ben le mercato le fameux le
marché cet été là va être va être très
très
très compliqué pour le psg et j'espérais
que
les bruits de faire venir
les zinédine zidane en tant
qu'entraîneur permettrait de garder de
garder la pépite m bape ait mellal
alors c'est pas confirmé mais il devrait
si normalement real madrid dans les deux
prochaines semaines à peu près c'est
mais c'était enfin moi je me lassais en
plus et en toute heure lui il a fait le
boulot dont l'une a fait le job il fait
déjà mais
il a fait lui début il fait le job voilà
donc la ccc dur c'est dur parce que
parce que je vous vois pas comment ils
vont réussir à pouvoir aller la chercher
par la suite ils sont blessés peut-être
passer leur chance peut-être quand on
voit ce cycle peut être qui prend fin
pierre chevallier sur un site d'une
longueur incroyable assez à ceux à ce
niveau-là de de guigne de malchance quel
que soit le moment où l'on utilise et
ses ahurissantes dire que chaque ce
début de saison les espoirs sont permis
on a on à ce qui se fait de mieux au
football eu dans le football européen
voire mondial et puis et c'est la marche
que la marche du bit iem de finale
quatre 4 autres aux pv
je fais juste un petit parallèle puisque
on en a parlé entre le le match de
versailles avec une première mi-temps
qui était plutôt maîtrisée en combat en
demi finale de coupe de france contre
nice celle du psg en première mi-temps
en huitièmes et d'assez remarquable de
maîtrise justement de maîtrise avec une
signature comme depuis les trente
derniers matches c'est la classe de
clients des deux qui diane mba mba paix
qui plante son but encore un beau but et
qui tient la baraque et puis mai et
après plus rien c'est l'effondrement
dont vous avez dont vous avez parlé
c'est le sait le sait la la la le néant
le nez en deuxième mi temps où le mental
lâche le physique lâche aussi le
collectif il y en a pas encore en moins
dans ces moments là et puis on a on a
vraiment l'impression que c'est un
empilement de talent et de et 2 cv long
comme le bras et de compte en banque que
assez à ses gars qui ne sont pas et qui
ne font pas des qui ne font pas des
titres qui ne crée pas des titres c'est
ahurissant contrôle comprend six ans il
faut savoir que chelsea a mis dix ans
pour gagner la ligue des champions on
arrose et voilà et donc c'est là que tu
l'as dit tout à l'heure c'est rolland
courbis qu'en parler il dit que en effet
au delà de 10 ans il faut cesser trop
c'est trop long et les objectifs
s'efface alors gens je sais vous êtes
passionné par le suédois veulent
connaître votre avis sur cette
élimination
14 au programme un tout avait organisé
sur l'amiante dont le bayern en ont
parlé du
calendrier de versailles pour arriver
jusqu'en demi finale celui du psg cette
année là il n'était pas il avait eu de
la chance ce tirage il avait pris il est
africain toutes les équipes les plus
faibles pour arriver en finale donc ils
vont en finale il à perdre d'accord
alors là on fait des gorges chaudes
manchester united a gagné 2 0 chez eux
perd 2,3 à la maison on peut dire allez
une fois c'est la guigne barça 4 0 ça ne
s'était jamais vu remonter le 4 0 berne
aussi seul c'est plus la ligne c'est
plus la guigne fort et il faut arrêter
de dire que les mecs ils ont pas de
chaise c'est par la chaîne y'a quoi il
ya quoi il ya deux joueurs deux joueurs
cliquer que mouiller le maillot ce mba
pv ratti après les messi mais messi ou
la boîte rejet par fin de carrière et la
boîte il est peut-être arrivé là tu l'as
d'or c'est là peut-être une jambe de
bois ont été comme ça mais il fallait
pas le pana ce moment là si les psy
c'est plus le messie c'est le cas de le
dire l'autre l'autre escroquerie de néma
alors lui qu'il n'a pas joué il n'a pas
joué ses cartes pour sade les matchs du
psg un garçon qui est qui gagnent des
millions ou sur qui on avait fondé sur
le meilleur joueur du monde et qui lui
aurait dû amener à mener le plus value à
l'équipe
c'est un échec total ces mecs là il se
lit sur le terrain il se promène sur un
terrain il se promène carton adn maps et
des vers à ti qui courent partout et qui
mouille le maillot pour le club mais
quand on a ces deux pseudos stars parce
que pour moi c'est des pseudos stars qui
sont là à à user
un périmètre de 2 5 mètres messi l'a
fait mais s'il a fait une grosse mi
temps
suffisant je suis d'accord c'est
passionata mais neuf ans plus tard il
s'appelle messi quand même une certaine
mais si donc là abandonné déjà arrêtons
de toujours prendre que des stars parce
que les stars comme tout sport collectif
c'est pas des réalités qu'il faut un
collectif c'est un gros collectif on le
voit très bien avec des équipes
manchester on le voit très bien avec
d'autres équipes qui ont des gros
collectif où j'ai plus l'équipe est là
qui jouaient en noir noir et jaune
l'allemande
dortmund qui a pas des stars mais qu'il
ya un collectif énorme et un coeur
énorme et c'est ce qui manque au psg
donc à mon avis dans la politique elle
est définie par le président le
directeur sportif alain serres de
charger leurs aînés hi-fi et leonardo
est ce qu'il faut les laisser sortir les
échanges et armando n'est abandonné il
ya les entraîneurs le psg c'est la valse
et z trailer et les autres couleurs ils
partent du pg et gagner des coupes mais
bien un malaise il ya un malaise c'est
pas la douleur que mauvais sauf que
l'entraîneur ait lâché le quoi je parle
l entraîneur si déjà elle n'a pas les
clés du camion si déjà on lui laisse pas
le temps de mettre en place ce qu'il
veut faire et ce qu'il veut amener il
faut il faut en temps il faut du temps
c'est pas des magiciennes dégâts laissez
les travailler le psg dès qu'un problème
c'est la faute de l'entraîneur non ce
n'était pas la faute de l'entraîneur car
il y deux ans les d'après ou de retrait
sur les entraîneurs à laisser les seuls
moyens sur les sols récemment fait deux
ça me fait 2 quand même deux entraîneurs
du psg qui sont partis que la découpe
laissons les entraîneurs qui sont
certainement des bons entraîneurs faire
leur boulot et c'est peut-être au niveau
de la hiérarchie en haut là où il faut
et dégagé peu et ils on touche le fond
pour moi au real ils ont touché le fond
et elle et l'après match c'est
scandaleux j'espère qu'ils vont ramasser
mais grave à quoi ils vont aussi quelque
chose du ct michael quand on lit
plusieurs enquêtes c'est comme si ces
gens c'est l'ambiance au sommet qui est
chaotique le tandem leonardo manhasset
en fait nasser n'est pas content que
leonardo et accès directement à l'émir
du coup ils essaient de saboter un peu
le travail de leonardo leonardo faut
savoir qui s'est mis à dos apparemment
tout le staff l'entraîneur l'équipe
féminine aussi l'ambiance de l'équipe
féminine avec la sphère queyranne raoui
et diallo c'est catastrophique les
jeunes aussi le lien est rompu entre
leonardo et les jeunes le poème
aujourd'hui au psg je pense c'est
peut-être là dessus aussi il faut pas
trop j'ai essayé de critiquer les
joueurs les entraîneurs il est peut-être
céder retombée je sais que je vais
proposer des versions studio on entend
souvent parler d'institutions paix et
dans des grands clubs et en effet à
paris il manque aussi ce centre
d'entraînement qu'il devrait être
mais ça fait donc voici un accord ça
fait dix ans que les cathares ils sont
là et c'est toujours pas fait donc là il
ya peut-être un dossier qui n'est pas
qui n'est pas traité de la bonne manière
je ne sais pas je ne connais pas assez
mais parce que psg ce n'est pas que
l'équipe de foot s'étaient pas que
l'équipe à deux c'est aussi une équipe
féminine c'est aussi un psg du judo
après j'ai eu un message d psg et donc
l'élimination mais ce que je veux dire
c'est
l'identité et que l'on va
comme sur une équipe de hockey sur glace
une équipe de basket où dortmund et donc
quand on est parisien on n'est pas juste
joueurs de l'équipe de foot on est aussi
partisan d'un grand club et ça peut-être
que cet esprit là n'est pas créée
n'existe pas très rapidement pierre
cheval et parce qu'il faut avancer aussi
après dans l'émission justin le match au
parc contre bordeaux qui a suivi
l'élimination m'a semblé extrêmement
révélateur de tout l'état d'esprit du
club
supporter a compris j'ai trouvé
d'ailleurs les supports que justement on
allait en parler
plutôt mesurés dans leurs dans leur
courroux est l'expression de leur colère
mais j'ai deux images celle à l'image de
de neymar et messi quand ils sont
copieusement sifflé par le parc mais ça
c'est incroyable c'est incroyable que ça
arrête mais et c'est justifié et c'est
justifié et la tête de pochettino sur
les trois buts il n'y a aucune
expression ya aucune expression il est
en tribunes et il n'y a pas deux il n'y
a pas de réaction c'est bordeaux on sait
que bordeaux fait une grande saison
quant à nous envier
paris gagne contre bordeaux oui et j'ai
essayé dernière chose c'est justement
cette incapacité parce que je pense que
c'est une incapacité à se rabattre sur
le championnat on a une équipe qui
domine le championnat ligue 1 depuis une
dizaine d'années maintenant là ils sont
obligés de s'en contenter eh ben ça va
pas ça va pas leur suffire et même
là aussi qu'il ya que mbeki qui surnage
en disant que maintenant c'est les
objectifs ont changé et qu'il faut être
champion de france ça va pas leur
suffire ça va se refaire à personne vous
faites mais ça reste quand même le
championnat derrière donc c'est bien de
renouer de renault comme avec et les
supporters justement les supporters qui
ont taggé le camp des loges à
saint-germain-en-laye qui ont taggé
aussi le parc des princes est ce que
vous le comprenez gens bien
que les joueurs soient sifflé les
joueurs tenu responsable de l'échec du
groupe soit sifflé par les supporters ça
je peux le comprendre après les
dégradations des mâchoires soit enfin on
jette un coup de barre à mine à la tête
bon ça c'est inadmissible inadmissible
l'indicible par contre juste le midi
libre antenne et finalement ils ont plus
prêté le terrain
versailles viviane parce que les
jardiniers
et des cif et du coup sûr messi est ce
que ça peut le faire partir peut-être ou
pas bixente qu'est ce que vous en pensez
est-ce qu'il fallait le sifflet mais si
finalement après après sa carrière tout
ce qu'il a ce qu'il a fait c'est une
grande première que messi se fasse
siffler dans son stade c'est compliqué à
dire mais clairement aujourd'hui le
bilan de messi n'est pas suffisant au
paris saint germain après
le problème des supporters c'est qu'ils
ne se reconnaissent plus dans le projet
du club c'est quoi on achète des grandes
stars ont fait un projet autour d'une
équipe on l'a on voit même le retour de
joueurs formés au club avec édouard
michao ou xavi simons
mais si c'était une opportunité pour moi
fallait la saisir quand tu vois que
messi libre tu le recrute le rendement
est pas suffisant le la vraie personne
qui devait ramener quelque chose au club
pour moi c'est neymar donc sifflé mais
si
je pense qu'il fallait siffler mais si
il faut lui montrer que quand on est
mécontent parce que ce genre de joueur
il va être blessée dans son amour propre
et il doit avoir un nazi le rapport qu'à
partir de maintenant et il a annoncé
aujourd'hui qu'il voulait rester de qui
vous voulez qu'ils voulaient rester
l'année prochaine qui voulait jouer au
psg l'année prochaine donc je les lui je
les lui juste avant l'émission donc de
ce côté là on peut être ré normalement
rassuré même si au foot on sait que
quelqu'un va rester généralement y
parvenir à ce qu'ils avaient annoncé des
discussions je crois avec ses proches et
donc donc voilà c'est je pense que voilà
il peut être blessé dans son amour
propre et dans son ego et avoir envie de
montrer qu'il est capable de donner
voilà maintenant
après c'est pareil mine de rien il faut
aussi un peu de temps quand on arrive
dans une nouvelle équipe et c'est vrai
que beaucoup de joueurs on leur meilleur
rendement au bout d'un an un an et demi
donc peut-être que l'année prochaine ce
ne sera que meilleur et ça ne pourra pas
être pire
meciar à barcelone il touché quasiment
tous les ballons il était c'était le
maître à jouer de l'équipe aujourd'hui
au pm au psg il n'a pas ce rôle là n'a
pas du tout ce rôle il est vrai que
forcément la star aussi c'est un peuple
qui aujourd'hui fait et il n'a pas sur
le terrain n'a pas le rôle de alors de
stars encore moins mais même au niveau
technique et tactique il n'a pas le rôle
qu'il avait à barcelone kaka aussi et
c'est vrai même temps d'adaptation pour
lui qui doit pas être évident parce
qu'il a beaucoup moins de ballons a
touché
c'est vraiment à bien prendre entre
démarrer entre messi et bab est
d'ailleurs
parti
malédiction des argentins en ligue 1 je
crois on dit souvent qu'ils mettent six
mois un an à s'adapter à marseille
notamment tous les argentins dit pas si
m 6 mois à s'adapter il ya des sportifs
ça ne te j'avais ce penalty a failli caf
a été accordé finalement qui est annulé
avec l'avare et où elle bat p prend le
ballon pour tirer et là c'était et c'est
là aussi c'est assez révélateur c'est
que exit messi exit neymar pour tirer le
penalty c'était cmap le taulier on va
passer à notre prochaine thématique on
passe notre page débats
elle va partir non on ne part pas bon
c'est pas grave on continue alors on va
parler de la guerre en ukraine
l'invasion russe a commencé le 8 mars
dernier désolé au niveau de l'ambiance
c'est beaucoup beaucoup moi je me suis
vu qu'une défaite du psg avec les
conséquences que l'on sait vous allez me
dire quel est le rapport avec les
yvelines et bien oui il y en a bien un à
poissy le club de football grâce à son
président olivier ses v ux d'origine
ukrainienne a accueilli cinq joueurs
professionnels ukrainien et leur
entraîneur ils sont arrivés en france ce
lundi 14 mars et joueur d'origine
ukrainienne jouer en deuxième division
le président de poissy voudrait les
faire jouer en nationale 2 dans les
prochaines semaines votre sentiment par
rapport à cette initiative de l'ice
poissy qui est recueil du coup cinq
joueurs ukrainiens et un entraîneur
ukrainien qu'est ce que vous en pensez
pierre plutôt positif fait d'elle c'est
très difficile d'aborder ces sujets là
dans le sport et dans le sport amateur
en particulier de parler politique ou de
parler géostratégie dans notre petit
landerneau
du sport yvelinois mais toutes les
initiatives campus multipliées en france
là et en europe pour accueillir les
ukrainiens qui fuient leur pays
sont sont bonnes à sont bonnes à saluer
parce que je crois pas je malgré les
images qu'on a qu'on a sur les chaînes
en continu en ce moment on n'imagine pas
ce qui se passe actuellement en ukraine
on n'imagine pas ce qui se passe sur la
terre européenne avec une avec ce qu'on
peut appeler une guerre et et je crois
que c'est en dessous de la réalité de ce
compte deux doses qu'on nous rapporte
donc évidemment à notre petit niveau du
sport et là le club le club de poissy le
peut le réaliser c'est bon à faire c'est
bon à prendre ça fait partie de cette
solidarité là et de ce que l'on peut
exprimer au monterey dans un dans un
conflit qui nous échappe totalement et
c'était loin d'être simple de les faire
venir il était en turquie sont arrivés à
par avion du coup ce lundi en fait ce
sont des ukrainiens qui ne sont pas
rentrés dans leur pays et s'ils rentrent
et forcément il allait faire et aller
faire la guerre du coup le président de
poissy qui est d'origine ukrainienne
s'est saisi de la sphère à trouver des
sponsors est allé voir certains clubs
alors je ne sais pas si je dois les
citer mais il ya certains clubs du
secteur qui vont les aider
financièrement ils vont aller recueillir
et peut-être jouer vont peut-être joué
du coup ans en nationale 2 dans les
prochains mois il essaye de les faire
jouer c'est aussi ça peut être
l'esprit du football du sport jean oui
certains
d'aidé ou de se demander ce que je crée
des passerelles mois par solidarité je
suis prêt à accueillir des ukrainiennes
si c'est ça le problème il n'y a pas de
problème et et voilà ça me visa même
s'il faut mais c'est vrai que dans le
monde du sport on ne peut que saluer
cette
initiative merci je les partis chez
d'ukrainiens michel je pense que là ce
n'est même plus une histoire de
politique c'est des personnes qui qui
souffre de la guerre comme disent les
gens dans leur pays même si enfin dans
les yvelines c'est la même chose on n'a
rien par exemple contre les habitants de
russie s'il ya des russes qui devait
venir dans les yvelines jouer pour des
clubs je pense qu'il serait pour fuir
leur pays je pense qu'il serait hébergée
aussi donc là c'est plus une question de
sécurité de dead à autrui on l'a vu le
sport est vraiment au coeur de se
confier eu l'exemple de roamad
abramovitch 1 le russe est obligé de
vendre chelsea en angleterre il ya eu
aussi cette image du gymnaste russe qui
avait un z un dessinée sur sa tenue pour
soutenir la russie l'équipe russe a
également été exclu de la prochaine
coupe du monde de football la question
sur cette thématique est ce que le sport
doit-il être apolitique dans ce conflit
oui ou non
non pour vous yann vous êtes partagés
vous faire un petit duel entre vos
bixente ah yan alors y est vous avez été
le premier et je dis non le sport ne
doit pas et le de toute façon le sport
n'est pas apolitique et aujourd'hui tous
les moyens pour pouvoir passer des
messages sont bons
malheureusement l'interlocuteur en face
n'a pas les oreilles pour les entendre
quels qu'ils soient et quelle que soit
la manière de lui transmettre des
messages donc bah oui en effet le sport
peut être un moyen de sanction et il
doit être à moins de sanctions pour pour
la russie parce qu'aujourd'hui on ne
peut pas accepter ce ce genre de
comportement et
quelques hics quel qu'il soit que ce
soit sur un nul craignent que ce soit
dans d'autres pays dans d'autres pays on
ne peut pas accepter la guerre et vivre
selon ce que l'on ce que l'on fait vivre
au peuple ukrainien aujourd'hui donc il
faudrait des zones ou alors créer sur
terre des zones ou alors les pays
peuvent aller combattre les uns en
entrant
3,6 g
jeudi que le foot est le sport doit
faire passer des messages et donc il ne
doit pas sorte sortir de ce type de
conflit il doit passer des messages en
disant vous devez arrêter vous devez
arrêter ces conflits les conflits
doivent se régler sur un terrain de foot
par exemple ou sur un match sur un
une table des chèques par exemple ce
serait un bon moyen de régler les
conflits
doit être apolitique maintenant le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui ne l'est
pas on va très bien que il ya quand il
ya des matches ici de l'israël au foot
il ya souvent des problèmes il ya un an
de soucis et là dessus il faut pas
confondre je pense pas faire passer des
messages de bienveillance là c'est par
rapport au soutien aux ukrainiens le
fait que les athlètes paralympiques
russe ne puisse pas représenter leur
pays c'est un autre débat mais c'est
aussi une question a soulevé est ce que
il aurait dû ou pas concourir
tout le monde c'est à dire que l'équipe
il ya déjà riez michel peytavy laisser
passer des messages c'est une chose le
sport c'est un trait sans un excellent
vecteur pour laisser passer les messages
politiques dans le sens où on a vu le
mouvement black l'animateur c'était très
important de véhicules et pour beaucoup
de joueurs dans le football dans le
football américain maintenant prendre
faut faire attention aussi à pas prendre
position
ouvertement par exemple quand on voit
roman abramovitch il a apporté
énormément chose à chelsea il se fait un
peu
éjecté comme ça du jour au lendemain est
ce que lui
ce qu'il a eu le temps de s'exprimer je
sais pas vraiment si peu coulé suite à
ces sanctions
devraient couler va couler
pierre chevallier qui vous a convaincu
j'étais partagé je reste je reste
partagé parce que on parle de sport en
parle ici sur ce plateau et on parle de
sport notamment amateurs et parfois de
sport professionnel je crois qu'il faut
il faut qu'on rappelle le contexte où on
est on est dans un dans un contexte non
pas inédit mais très inhabituel pour
notre ère moderne parce que on est on
n'a pas eu de guerre mondiale depuis
depuis 1945 là on a un pays qui agresse
un autre qui qui ont veillé à un autre
et encore une fois on a pas on a
vraiment on est loin d'avoir tous les
éléments politiques et stratégiques de
ceux de ce conflit en devenir et on a on
a une scène nationale siona halle en
ukraine et internationales européennes
qui est en train de s'organiser avec
uniquement la c arms et ce sont des
sanctions sanctions économiques là on
parle de sanction sportive donc c'est à
dire de toute façon on va essayer de
taper là où ça fait mal de nos jours
taxer pas la finale de la ligue des
champions qui devait se dérouler à saint
pétersbourg a été délocalisé à à paris
c'est un symbole on gèle les actifs
d'abramovitch à chelsea pour le dos que
de la couronne britannique gèle ses
actifs on tape dans le portefeuille des
oligarques russes on tape sur l'économie
russe le rouble et s'est écroulé et pour
le coup peut être assez vite en
cessation de paiement donc on se bat
avec nos armes je ferai juste en
parallèle avec du de sport avec les
valeurs dire que la la le sport peut
véhiculer des messages et des valeurs et
dire sanctionné en annonçant qu on ne
cautionne pas une attitude quand c'est
une attitude en plus guerrière
moi je ne suis personne pour pouvoir
dire quoi que ce soit par rapport à par
rapport à ceux à ce conflit
quant à dire que le sport 2 doit être
apolitique ou pas je pense qu'il peut
être une tribune d'expression par des
sanctions notamment et comme c'est le
cas avec les athlètes
qui sont qui sont exclues pékin et qui
sont exclues de la coupe du monde de
foot et de toutes les compétitions
internationales après après le prendre
position au delà de ça je pense que
c'est il faut que les sportifs et les
fédérations internationales restent à
leur place c'est pour ça que j'étais
assez assez partagés encore une fois par
rapport à 1 par rapport à un contexte
qui nous échappe grandement autre
personne qui n'a pas réussi à se décider
sur cette question jean alors vous
qu'est ce que vous en pensez gt gt comme
pierre acheter j'étais entre les deux
pourquoi parce que pour moi sportivement
mais les sportifs y sur le broyer
malheureusement et que et ce qu'apple
ait quelqu'un paie les pots cassés
notamment au tennis le numéro un mondial
qui voit là tu crois pas des femmes
défendre son titre sur prochain tournoi
maintenant bien sûr le
c politique et là on essaie de taper
partout pour essayer de d'isoler le
président actuel pour que tout le monde
lui tourner le dos et notamment avec les
grosses fortunes parce que là il ya
peut-être ce levier qui va faire que là
ils vont peut-être lui dire un toc toc
toc là faut peut-être arrêter parce que
nous on veut bien financer un parce
qu'il doit être financé quand même aimé
attention donc je fasse que tout est
fait pour isoler isoler le président de
la russie actuelle et et que
malheureusement il ya des pots cassés le
sport en pâtit de sa et et c'est dommage
mais c'est à mon avis nécessaires pour
faire cesser ces c'est malheureusement
se complique et dramatique pour les
ukrainiens donc pas de faux pas mélanger
sport et politique du coup vie j'étais
parce qu est-ce qu on est on sait si les
sportifs russes qui ne peuvent pas
pratiquer son plan contre la gare en
aussi bon on a vu l'athlète qui avait le
z je crois que c'est plutôt clair mais
tout ce qui est laid sportingbet
oui aussi sinon mais c'est délicat après
ce que le risque s'est battus aussi
d'isoler les russes qui ne peuvent plus
pratiquer et qui se disent ba ba c'est
un autre débat c'est plus dans le sport
mais qui se disent pourquoi le monde ne
veut plus nous c'est pas nous qui avons
décidé cette guerre dont le sport
devrait pas être politique maintenant il
ya de l'argent il ya de la visibilité
alors forcément c'est politisé c'est
certain alors on a de la chance parce
qu'en région nous a offert six minutes
d'émission en vend plus du coup on
pourra parler de la dernière thématique
on va continuer du coup par un sujet un
peu plus léger on va parler de
paris-nice le départ de cette édition
2022 était donné à mantes-la-ville
l'événement réunit plusieurs milliers de
personnes on écoute les réactions des
spectateurs venus sur la ligne de départ
ça rappelle événement vous regarde le
tour de france on les voit qu'on les
fasse dans les yvelines
c'est sympa de voir ça va autour de chez
nous et pour le coup je reste parce que
j'habite à mantes la ville et je suis
niçoise
on a quoi la très content d'être là
c'est un super événement pendantla
disent franchement en heureux d'être là
alors le lendemain c'est la petite
commune d'auffargis 2000 habitants qui a
eu le privilège d'organiser le départ et
le maire était a ravi on l'écouté un
moment de fête comme je le disais c'est
pas voir mon nom exceptionnel parce que
toute la population a joué le jeu et
puis j'ai la chance d'avoir une grosse
équipe de bénévoles qui nous ont
beaucoup aidés parce que ça nécessite
quand même de l'installation du barrage
et autres et donc c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment un bon moment de fun alors
depuis treize ans le départ du paris
nice est donné depuis les yvelines avec
une grosse commune le dimanche est une
petite commune le lundi c'est à chaque
fois le programme on écoute le directeur
du paris nice sur le choix de fabrice ce
qui me plaisent déjà je la connais parce
que je la reprends ta c'est souvent à
vélo et puis encore une fois le le
cyclisme doit aller partout on doit
aller dans les petites communes on amène
des champions notre stade c'est sur les
communes des petites communes dans quel
champion viennent danser stade là donc
c'est merveilleux et puis bon on est
toujours bien accueilli bien évidemment
ça fait donc treize ans que le paris
nice par des yvelines la question sur ce
thème est ce que c'est toujours un
événement ce départ de paris nice depuis
les yvelines oui ou non non pour vous y
allez jarrier ont fait un petit duel
avec avec jean jean vous commencez à
jouer
mais bien sûr paris se veut partie des
grands classiques du cyclisme le
français et que c'est un événement c'est
un des plus beaux événements du cyclisme
et qui est suivi qui est suivi par par
les spectateurs et les téléspectateurs
donc pour moi en plus l'honneur pour
nous en yvelines
qu'il parte des yvelines c'est très très
bien et c'est très très bien et ça et
chantent tous les ans cette année là un
bus ils avaient le choix dans la date
donc
elle était elle était bien qu elle était
bien organisée elle était bien une fête
et donc il ya aucun souci pour quel
souci là dessus c'est une belle
compétition elle doit perdurer yann
alors non ce n'est plus un event c'était
plus un événement un événement c'est
quand quand il y à cette exceptionnalité
et là du fait que ça fait 13 ans que sa
part des yvelines fait que ce n'est plus
exceptionnel c'est devenu une habitude
maintenant la ferveur auprès des des
supporters et des spectateurs restent
reste bien présente et en effet il faut
que cela perdure moi j'espère que l'on
va pouvoir encore avoir plusieurs
événements plusieurs années encore le
parent et liste dans les yvelines au
minimum jusqu'en 2025 et on parle même
de peut-être de 2030 mais c'est très
bien parce que c'est une région terre de
cyclisme on a quand même de moins en
moins souvent les dernières étapes du du
tour de france donc voilà on à paris
nice en début d'année souvent plus avec
une météo qui est quand même un peu un
peu favorable d'ailleurs il avait coiffé
meilleur à paris que à nice à 10
donc ça s'appelle la course du la course
au soleil bon bah là c'était un peu un
petit peu inversés mais donc voilà c'est
vrai que c'est quand même très très
agréable moi j'ai surtout envie qu'ils
nous refassent la même étape que tu à
coignières quand on a vu le contre la
montre enfin un prologue ben amor ben
ouais j'ai fait comme très très proches
les deux et j'ai eu tous ces morts pas
mais donc donc voila un petit contre la
montre un petit prologue sur la 1ère
étape ça fait ça fait longtemps et ça
c'est quelque chose que j'attends avec
impatience les chaînes télé alors vous
non pour vous c'est plus rêver le mans
bat comme disent comment disait ça fait
déjà 13 ans et qu'on a pu voir aussi
avec l'étape du tour de france à
mantes-la-jolie l'année dernière le tour
de france quand même autre chose
il ya beaucoup plus d'engouement sur une
étape du tour de france après ça et
c'est logique
il ya aussi beaucoup de monde qui
manquent on peut regretter ça aussi sur
le paris-nice beaucoup de cyclistes pour
en citer quelques-uns pougatchev richie
porte thibaut pinot alaphilippe les
sprinteurs caribéens spectateurs ont dit
ce jour là il manque à la fille c'est
vraiment lui qui manque sur ce
paris-nice pour faire passer le pari
d'une autre ère en fait mais après on
l'appelle quand même le mini tour de
france puisqu'il ya onze vainqueur de la
course qui ont remporté leurs premiers
paris nice avant de remporter leur
premier tour de france la roue glitch à
son premier paris nice maintenant la
question c'est est ce que il va avoir
son premier tour de france
evans est difficilement battable je
pense pour le tour de france la messe
oui j'ai peur que l'année soit déjà dit
pierre sueur et il reste une minute
après on se fait taper sur les doigts et
bien plutôt convaincu pas d'argent parce
que je lui dis il n'y a rien de mal dans
une habitude et c'est du propre
justement de tout l'est de tous les
événements sportifs
roland garros a lieu tous les ans face
aux fins d ovide et ça reste un
événement est jeune et c'est vrai pour
tous les événements sportifs et je pense
que pour les pour toutes les communes
des grandes mais petit des yvelines ça
reste un événement qui s'organise et
qu'il prend de l'ampleur justement est
qui et qui est télévisé médiatisé donc
oui ça reste ça reste toujours sur la
sellette
merci ça sera le mot de la fin pierre
chevallier merci beaucoup c'est déjà la
fin de cette émission on va terminer
comme d'habitude par une citation
aujourd'hui je vous propose une citation
de zinedine zidane qui pourra peut-être
faire réfléchir les joueurs du psg les
dirigeants du psg les performances
individuelles ce n'est pas le plus
important on gagne et on perd en équipe
je vous laisse méditer sur cette phrase
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
non
oui